I'm gonna talk to you about Unicode and
we're going to go down the rabbit hole
I've made all the slides to indicate
what year were on because Unicode is
across a couple of millennia so it's
probably good idea to keep track of what
you're in for any given information some
things might not apply yet because they
haven't been invented so right now we're
in 2019 we're going to talk about why
I'm giving this talk because why me then
we're going to talk about the written
word the computerized word somebody
invented Unicode for a reason so we'll
talk about that will go into C++ and
Unicode and how much that actually means
how much works how much doesn't work
what kind of stuff we're going to do and
then I'm going to talk about the Future
Perfect which is of course where we're
going so let's get started with why I'm
doing this so way back
we're in 1994 I'm a small kid in the
primary school I'm learning German for
the first time and they have all weird
words so I figured I'll make a computer
program because that's just who I am
I'll make it ask me a question say if it
says the word ample which is a traffic
light I'll reply in the Dutch word stop
lift and then vice versa
that's a good idea and I had a friend
who's actually German who has a keyboard
that has all characters on it and we
figured well we'll try this Mabel make
it work so we programmed it in gw-basic
because 94 and we tried it and it sucked
because I had leading spaces that meant
that if you accidentally typed the space
in front of your word it said nope you
got wrong if you had a training space
nope got it wrong if you made a case
difference you got it wrong and then I
tried to run it at home and I figured
out that I couldn't even answer half the
questions because there were accents on
the letters and my keyboard doesn't have
those letters so I can't even type the
answer even if I know it so yeah it
works on his computer but it doesn't
even work on mine I can't even try it
myself
okay so let's skip ahead a bit now let's
talk about yak shaving who's ever heard
of yak shaving okay so some of you will
have heard the story some of you will
have not what is yak shaving actually
thing is doing a series of tasks
which are nested inside other tasks that
you think are accomplishing a goal and
every task seems to follow on the
previous one but in the end you're doing
something completely unconnected to what
you're trying to do so the colloquial
story starts that I want to wax my car
but in order to wax my car I need to fix
my hose so I'll go to Home Depot and buy
a new hose but home peoples in the other
side of the Tappan Zee Bridge and I need
there an easy path to get there
so I'll borrow the one from our neighbor
that's it still sort of reasonable at
this point but Bob is angry with me
because I borrowed his mushi pillow and
he was not gonna let me that thing
unless I returned that pillow but the
pillow I can't return because some of
the stuffing fell out and I kinda just
gave it back half empty and it's a yak
hair pillow so I need to get some yak
hair to fill the pillow so it can give
him that get my EZ Pass his e-zpass go
across a bit go to Home Depot buy you a
length of tube and wax the car so now
I'm at the zoo I'm shaving a yak so that
I can wax my car so that's roughly how I
work so let's go into what I did so I
had a miniature train set and I wanted
to make a control system for it but not
just one with buttons physical things I
mean this is like 2,000 at this point I
have a computer it has a nice display it
has a parallel port I can use that to
control things I won the nice screen I
want it to look nice so I need to have
some UI system to display all my nice UI
things I need to edit the track in real
time on display rotate things around but
I'm not gonna make this Andaz and
definitely not Windows and ok I'll go
make an operating system so we'll go
deep into making an operating system and
three years later I'm a moderator at OS
dev org okay I may have gone a bit far
made most of an operating system kernel
called Atlantis OS you can still find it
online on SourceForge because github
didn't exist yet even though I think I
did put it on get it by now and at that
point I sort of start entering corporate
live 2006 have less time to work on it
so sort of stopped working on it
but at that point I start working on my
corporate codebase and I get entangled
in strings because we have a code base
it has 26 string classes a couple utf-8
utf-16 a couple companies specific ones
a whole lot of transcoding from back and
forth and translating to things things
in your locale which is platform
specific stuff that you really don't
want to get into but we will don't worry
so I'm back into Unicode and I figured
well actually I'd like to pick up my
operating system project again but while
doing that at work I realized why is
there so little C++ support for Unicode
in 2012 I mean this is this is starting
to get ridiculous we couldn't use C++ 11
because of course you can't use it the
year after is released it takes at least
like half a decade in companies but even
if we could it wouldn't have had much it
would have had a utf-16 string and
utf-32 string but no methods of getting
data in or out of it other than some
methods but nothing nice and nothing
useful so yeah ok so we get back to
operating system development still a
moderator it's 2016 at this point so
that's like decade and a half and I
restarted my project and I decided to
rename it to apologize for the
butchering of your language written yes
this is a pure coincidence and I'm first
presenting this at a conference in
Norway I did not intend it that way
three years ago but it just happens so I
try that and I do that because it has an
accented letter in it which means that
if I try to the Unicode I must support
Unicode otherwise it can't even print
his name okay that works
got it working it's working on a
Raspberry Pi I can boot it I can have a
login screen with a nice I can have a
red wine glass it says its own name
everything is Unicode everything works
up to a point because it's still just
printing letters I'm not combining
things I'm not doing anything
complicated so a rabbit doesn't work
most people in the world wouldn't be
able to use it because it just wouldn't
work for them and at that point I go to
a conference talking about something
else a mocking framework in this case
and I made two people from copper spice
so Barbara Geller and
and summertime and they tell me that
they have the solution to string
problems because they created cs string
which does all the things that i didn't
do and i figured well this sounds like a
good idea maybe you should put this in
standard C++ and they are like sounds
great but we're doing copper spice would
you mind taking this and sort of running
with it to the standard committee and go
and put it in there okay of course why
not I mean let's go you actually some
more so I joined the C++ standards
committee join SG 16 specifically for
Unicode and start working out a proposal
for strings starting on C astraying
expanding on it create my own github
repository with some proposals stuff in
there that's probably going to
understand it hopefully in some years so
2018 we do that informally 2099
officially joined the C++ committee so
yeh committee member we complete C++ 20
make sure that there's nothing in there
there's going to hamper us from getting
proper steering classes in so we try to
get rid of all the you know standard
specified ways of making crap language
and we try to make sure everything is
supportable from that point on okay so
that basically brings us to just about
now and at this point were like four
months ago there's a new Raspberry Pi
out and unlike all the other ones before
it it has a documented USB controller so
that was the thing holding you back so
I'm back up making an operating system
again yay
so we're here about unicode so this is
why I'm doing Unicode I've hit it like
four or five times already it's just
gonna keep coming back until we solve it
so let's get to the history of the
written word who can tell me what script
this is here we glyph yes
Egyptian hieroglyph used from a 32
century BC up until 394 and that number
is because that's the last date that
they found something actually written in
hieroglyphs and they are pretty sure
that it died out at that point because
after that point nobody wrote it and
nothing could be found anymore it uses
three kinds of ways to use a letter and
originally it started out by having just
a literal meaning so looking at these
who can tell me what these hieroglyphs
mean
in case you're hesitant they literally
mean what they look like so the first
one is not the wheel because wasn't
invented yet 3200 BC come on it's the
Sun the second one is a read and the
third one is a mountain so there we go
basically introduction hieroglyphs then
they move to having them as symbolic
things so they would be used as for
example a read or a Sun but more in the
symbolic meaning of light and then they
want to use them as a letter so they
started making series of of tokens in a
row that meant some some kind of word or
concept that they didn't have something
visual to express for example the color
blue unless you have blue paint is
really hard to express with the symbols
so at that point they were still mostly
writing on stone or carving into stone
and these hieroglyphs are really
complicated so other languages will have
more simple tokens than this so let's go
to the next one who knows what script
this is Chinese I heard Chinese anybody
else nobody else Japanese do we have a
third option yes Korean we have a fourth
option actually this is a trick question
because all of these are Chinese but
there's nothing about it that could tell
you it's Chinese because there are four
countries using the same script so
Chinese Japanese Korean and Taiwanese
and Hong Kong and Vietnam so there's a
couple of people using the same kind of
script but the first people to use it as
far as I could find was Chinese in 1200
ish BC and we call these kinds of
characters Han characters so that's what
the name comes from in Chinese Han Zi
Han category and every letter used to be
a complete word so you have monosyllabic
words it's just a single syllable for a
word a single letter and at some point
they started transferring to by syllabic
words and that's still currently most of
the
these words they just have two symbols
for them and in this case we have fairly
recognizable symbols as well although I
will admit that I forgot what the first
one was it's not a letter it's 1200 BC
books haven't been invented so that's
not it the second one though that's a
tree or wood depending on which way you
interpret it so at some point they start
evolving to police elaborate words so
let's go to the next script this is
Hebrew and Hebrews interesting because
on one hand it's one of the very few
languages said completely died out and
then got back it's also one of the very
few languages written from right to left
which means that you start reading all
the way on the right and then leads to
the left go to the next line and so on
I've had to remove the dot at the end of
the last line because my editor would
put it on the wrong side yeah a bug into
the presentation software it's not the
first so we have Hebrew it's interesting
because it's right to left but otherwise
it's still just letters and we still
have just letters for alphabets so this
is the Hebrew Aleph and this is a Hebrew
Beth so it's still just the language
like Greek but interestingly enough it's
all earth in Greek so this started
around thousand BC and Greek started
around 800 BC give or take let me like
the century and Greek is what we think
the name alphabet came from so we've had
Alpha Beta Gamma and so on we just took
the first two bits alphabet so we have
an alphabet it's an adaptation of the
Phoenician alphabet which I'm not
showing because it's not relevant to the
rest and we don't have time and it's
evolved greatly during actual use and
here's a bit of an example of what Greek
looks like left to right that's an easy
to read and they still have most of the
lightest that we nowadays use in
mathematics and in physics yes thank you
and then we go to the one script that I
almost forgot to put in the talk Latin
because it seems so obvious because we
use it all day and I just completely
forgot to mention it but that was
invented after Greek and it came from
Greek through Etruscan to Latin and
Latin has just a lumber of ladders he
have consonants or vowels and a group of
those forms a syllable and how you
pronounce these syllables differs
greatly between everybody and a country
between countries which means that if
you have something written in Latin
there is no way of figuring out how to
pronounce it unlike the number of other
script but this does mean that most of
the world nowadays has Latin script
which means that this is going to shape
a whole lot of character encoding but
let's get back to what we had in the
east because we have Japanese and
Japanese call this kanji kanji where
kanji means Han characters it's a
slightly different pronunciation but
it's the same kind of thing and it's
actually the exact same character said
as Chinese but Japanese didn't just
write left-to-right like we expect
initially they wrote top to bottom right
to left as in like this if this reminds
you of the matrix that's for a really
good reason because the matrix scrolling
text that that animation that most
people seem to know that's Japanese
characters as well and according to one
source that I found it's actually sushi
recipes so just in case you watch the
matrix go learn to make sushi so to read
this you would start all the way on the
right read from top to bottom and at the
end of the sentence you go back to the
top and read the next sentence and again
these are the complicated hanji
characters kanji in this case so these
are still fairly complicated to read you
need to learn thousands of letters to be
able to read it
Japanese primary school will teach you
about 1,800 to 2,000 just to be able to
read basic text and the total set is at
least 50,000 so we have Japanese and
then we go to Arabic we're doing this in
chronological order Japanese was a 5780
now we're in 200 at its ligature based
language which means that if I take a
word I'm going to go all the way over
here if I take a word written in Arabic
and I've been
this is the name of Arabic in Arabic and
I separate all the letters with space
they change form so in order to read
this you don't just need to read the
letters you need to understand how those
letters combine into the ligature which
also means that if we tried to render
this I couldn't just make a font with
all the letters and print them after
another and expect that to work and be
readable because it doesn't even look
like it just as an example this
character corresponds to this character
and while you can recognize the top of
it being over here the bottom is just
disappeared so ligatures are a really
complicated thing to deal with but what
if I tell you you've been watching
ligatures your whole life and never
realize it so let's have some ligatures
can anybody spot them you need to have
pretty good eyes to see them because the
font isn't that big I've made it as big
as words with a lie but these are all
ligatures in all of these words so let's
make them a bit bigger so we can see the
difference you'll see that in these
cases the letters combine to make a
single thing and if you separate them
there is a trick in Unicode to do that
they will print as separate letters you
can see the difference and as far as I
can understand this is done to make it
slightly more readable especially in the
FI case and many fonts and not this one
in the FI ligature the dot on the I
would disappear because the bow of the F
would obscure its space and make it hard
to read so in that case the ligature is
used to make sure that you don't have a
separate dot on the eye so he can read
it more easily incidentally I found a
second bug in the presentation software
doing this because as soon as I typed
these words and I tried to go with my
cursor through them to insert the
non-breaking the zero with a non joiner
to make sure that they didn't join I
found out that the presentations from
fur doesn't allow me to by the time I
retired the word that is rendered with a
ligature it ignores arrows to the left
until it gone past the entire ligature
just saw
of keeping the cursor at the right
second bug I still know to report that
one
so ligatures let's go to the next script
we need to do a few more before we go on
so we have Japanese second time we have
hiragana somebody's discovered that
actually learning 2,000 letters is
complicated and not practical so they
made a simplified kana virus and it only
has like 50 letters it's way easier and
these are pretty close in alphabet
because most of these correspond
directly to a sound use the user has
this as a handwriting and that led to a
number of different forms of each of the
letters which meant that you could not
read some of them because people used a
a style that you can read think for
example the Zetas we currently have
where some people add a curl at the
bottom unless you know that you're not
gonna have an easy time reading that and
at some point they decided this is a
terrible idea we need to standardize
this we take this set of letters these
are standard and these are old and they
decided to call the new stuff in
hiragana and the old stuff hantai ghana
so you can still write it and read it
it's just a new name for the same
character said it used to be and this is
an example of the kind of letters you
see I'm pretty sure these are the ones
used in the matrix so then we go from
Japan to three guesses Japan again
because Japan has a third character set
and it's called katakana and katakana is
not used for Japanese words katakana is
a simplified way of writing down
Japanese letters for foreign words so we
have Ghana in katakana and this is
fairly readable the thing is that if you
take a foreign word it doesn't
necessarily translate easily so I've
taken my name and translated it to
katakana so this is Peter who bit the
lutes except that you'll notice my name
has an R and it has an L and yes it's a
stereotype but it's also actually in the
language because these are the same
letter
Japanese only has one sound to represent
this and that means that they will have
to represented by the same character
which means that if they read the one on
the left
nobody's going to notice that different
than my name anymore it's just lost so
this is not lossless so now we go to a
very different kind of language and one
of the most special ones that I'm going
to talk about only for one reason which
is Irish autumn and this one's
interesting because it's the only
language that has a space that is not
white space if you want to write the
white space you have to write a dash and
that is because initially it was a
language used on quarters of stones
which meant that if you wanted to mark
something on one side you chopped out a
bit of stone the other side chopped out
a bit of stone but at no point is that
edge gonna disappear so if you want to
space you just leave some stone edge
there but that means that if you try to
transcribe that to some kind of written
form which people in 17th century did
when trying to decipher this this text
they had to use like this they have an
indication on the left saying this is
where the the brick starts the letters
and then an education on the right
saying this is where the brick ends if
you want to use this space it has to be
a line otherwise it just doesn't make
any sense so there I go our assumptions
white space is not always white space so
let's go to the next one we go to Korea
because Korea also made a simplified
alphabet they used to use hanji honja
sorry about the mispronunciations is
horrible and they try to make a
simplified alphabet and they simplified
it into simple characters like these but
when writing they compose them into more
complicated characters so the first we
combine into this character and the
second three combine into that one which
means that if you want to print this we
need to have something shaping our text
to make clear that these this is how
they combine so again another
complication and here's an example in
Korean we go back to kanji because right
now we're in 1946 and something really
important happened and at this point
Japan decides to simplify that character
set because all those old kanji they
were
complicated for reasons that weren't
applicable anymore so they decided to
replace some of the most complicated
characters by new characters that are
simpler so they had the old characters
they called him QD tie and they replaced
him with this newer character set called
Shinji Thai which basically means now
you have the old writing and the new
writing which would be okay until the
Chinese did the same and they simplified
you to zhang hua zi simplified chinese
which everybody in china mainland
currently uses but people in taiwan and
hong kong decided not to so they still
use the original one japan is on to
their own system trying to use a
simplified chinese and it's a giant mess
so people from probably of trying to
make this and it's similar but not the
same as japan so we have for example
this character which means stack and
this is in the original Hansie it's also
in what would be qg thai kanji except
that Google Translate won't accept that
anymore if you try to put this in
Japanese it's just gonna say no idea
what this is if we take the Japanese one
it's the same character except they
simplified the right side to only have
three dashes and a single symbol and
then the Chinese came along and did the
same thing except I removed one more so
they are not compatible anymore and
we'll get to that as soon as we get to
the written word because this leads to a
giant conflict in Unicode so let's exit
the written word we've had all the
scripts we need to go on to the
computerised word and we start back in
1963 it's a nice continuation it's just
three years later and at this point both
ascii and epic are both created there is
created in the same year an ascii is
designed as a new encoding it starts
with all the letters in consecutive
order and it's a 7-bit encoding which
means you only need seven bits to
represent it which means on your modem
you can get like 10% extra speed which
is important if you only get like seven
characters a second now you get eight
that's a big difference an episodic was
designed to be a bit and compatible with
punch cards which is also relevant
because most people use punch cards
to explain what I mean by compatible
with punch cards and why that's a good
thing let me show you so reading this we
get the numbers one through nine then we
get the letters so a through I J through
I think our yes to our and then over
here we skip one we should have had zero
and one being punched out but somebody
realized that if you did that you'd have
a hole of two one two holes next to each
other that week is the card so you can't
do that you'll have to skip one so both
an uppercase and lowercase episodic you
skip one after your R so you get an S
that is one further than you thought it
would be and also they're all in a block
from one through nine which means that
zero is not used and a through F in hats
are not used which means that if you
look at this on a computer it just
looked like a mess but if you look at it
on a punch card it makes a lot of sense
so this mostly died out after punch card
died out except at one company that's
still using it in 2019 and of course
that's gonna be relevant so we have
China and China discards we have
computers we want to be able to express
ourselves we want to be able to type our
letters so they took ASCII extended it
with a variable length multiple
character set called GB
twenty-three-twelve and gb stands for oh
yeah young-soon just national standard
so Chinese national standard Chinese
character set we can encode Chinese and
this encodes about 7,000 letters so it's
not even covering all of it at that
point in time America goes further and
we get an Z who here has heard of the
ante character set that's about half the
room the big problem is that an Zi the
company or the American National
Standards Institute actually has nothing
to do with this because this is code
page 437 in das yeah so this is usually
referred to as extended ASCII because
it's like a ski but you know extended
the bottom half at a ski it's code page
437 from das and the top are fulfilled
with a bunch of line drawing symbols or
some things in math stuff that would be
useful if you're an American
so that's fine until you go to Russia
here we get codepage 866 which has the
bottom half filled this asking of course
and the top are filled with Cyrillic
characters which is fine until you get
to you know Europe because we need other
characters to be able to be spell Buuren
so we have code page 850 which is the
bottom half is asking the top half is
line drawing and accented characters
incompatible because if we get some math
from the US now we're not going to be
able to read it and then we get two
windows just four years later in 1985 we
get windows codepage 1250 - which is
bottom half is ascii yet again top half
is text processor symbols accented
characters and some other useful things
like the Euro symbol although the Euro
would be introduced like 20 years later
which is fine unless you are a D and you
want to type Hebrew because then you
trace to codepage 1250 5 yeah we could
go on for quite a while more go page 12
55 is the same thing again top half is
Mon is Hebrew and incidentally if you
thought about an Zi Lai tak calls
lineage 1252 knew Angie even though of
course it's not Angie either so let's go
for a standard instead of having all
these windows and das filled pages by
some company making them let's go first
standards ISO 8859 we have standardized
8-bit code pages 15 of them and we can't
mix them because there's no way to mix
them or switch from them so this doesn't
actually help a lot we're going to leave
the West aside for a bit we're gonna go
back to China because trying to figure
it out that our code page or set of GB
23:12 is not enough we only have seven
thousand characters we need like
twenty-three thousand so they took that
and they add a little whole lot more
hold it gbk not an official standard but
practically Windows supports this so
yeah it works for them and this brings
us to what happens if you read something
in the wrong encoding because we have a
lot of encodings at this point we have
some Chinese and codings that nobody
else understands what happens if you
the wrong thing well then you get mochi
baked emoji baked is basically I took
some text in one encoding I didn't know
the encoding I just applied some
encoding and then it gave me something
so one of the most common once we get
nowadays is people sending you stuff in
utf-8 and you reading it in iso 8859-1
the sort of standard accepted latin one
character set which for example means
that if you're Billy O'Neal with an
apostrophe and you encoded that a pass
for you as the nice slanted apostrophe
in Unicode you get called Billy
something Neil if you ever see that one
you now know what it was and this is
still a problem nowadays because people
get post address to that I'm trying to
show how to read that so and 3/4 iry
with an accent on it and Plunket even
though their name is just Noreen
Plunkett yeah so this is a new
misspelling somebody did something wrong
and if you make your own computer
programs you'll get the same thing so
this is somebody trying to say hello and
it doesn't work at all because the wrong
character set is used for displaying the
result in 2019 awesome but sometimes
people know that this happens people
understand that moji big happens so at
some point somebody tried to send a
letter to a friend the friend type for
her email address out or physical
address sent it by computer somebody
received it notice that there were some
unrecognizable symbols and figured well
this must be Russian person is in Russia
so I guess I'll just take these things
write them on the letter send the letter
and then get to the post office and they
received this which is literally written
out emoji baked and somebody at the post
office was clever enough to realize this
looked up the usual way that mode you
bake happens with Russian people reverse
the process write out the actual name
above it so if you can read Russia this
says Russia and then deliver it to the
correct address person even though it
was completely mangled damn so it can
happen but don't count on it just try
not to make this so let's go to Unicode
because Unicode was at this point
invented it's 1991 we've gone back just
a little bit because mode yu-baek
happens now and Unicode was created to
have a simple reliable workable world
text encoding Joe Becker this is this
sounds like a smart person somebody who
knows what he's doing somebody who has
everything under control and he's not
likely to make some kind of obvious
simple mistake so I'll continue to quote
Unicode could be roughly described as
white body ASCII that's been stretched
to 16-bit because in a properly
engineered design 16 bits is more than
sufficient sorry Joe
yeah so unicode it includes graphemes
rather than glyphs which means that if
you have a different way of writing a
letter it's still the same letter and
they're not gonna allocate two spaces
it's gonna use one
it's a wide-body ASCII which means it's
just bigger and you use two bytes for
everything was incorporated on the 3rd
of January 1991 they published the first
volume in October so at that point we
have a problem because we want to encode
all current languages in this and we
have Chinese Japanese Taiwan Korea all
using a character set was like 30,000
letters your mathematics is going to
tell you that doesn't fit so we have a
16-bit character set gbk already has 20
1886 and we have four of them to put in
there so that's 80,000 we only have
60,000 so we're gonna tell basically
everybody using these character sets
that I'm sorry you deviated back in 50s
and 60s but we're going to merge you
back together so this is referred to as
Han unification and this is very
contentious thing because it also means
that in some cases you have different
letters you have different ways of
writing the letter and there is no way
in the text to figure out which one to
use which means that your your text
could come out unreadable just because
your font is wrong most of them are fine
and some have different lifts and they
now have the same graphene if you look
at an overview you'll notice that most
of these are the same across the row
except for tiny details for example this
one this one has a accent on the left
simplified Chinese it has an accent
connected to the rest in traditional
Chinese same thing here
Korean simplified it the same way and
Japanese simplified it differently but
these are all the same Unicode code
point so if you have some text and your
phone is set to Chinese you cannot read
this Japanese text to somebody tell
thank you
which is very impractical if you're
working in China with a Japanese company
suddenly they send you text that you
can't read as Japanese because it
doesn't make any sense that brings up
the question what actually is a
character so the one on the top you
probably realize this isn't a and that's
me but they're completely different so
the rationale is that because they are
both an A and the difference is just
stylistic as in it's just a different
rendering of an A we call both of these
in a and dig map to the same code point
the second one is two Chinese characters
and in this case they decided actually
the grapheme is different because it
represents a different concept even
though the glyphs are just about the
same thing so that's Han unification and
then we get to one of the newer
atrocities committed in the landscape of
characters somebody invented a way to
send Smiley's so we're talking about
Microsoft in Outlook so what happens if
you type is smiley and outlook in 94
that's gonna make it into an actual
smiley symbol how does it do that
because it doesn't have a font with
emoji because they are not invented yet
that's 97 we're in 92 so somebody made a
font that has Smiley's and other nice
things to show so we have wingdings we
have all sorts of nice things to put in
our email we can tell people that we
open the folder we can tell people were
waiting on them
and we can send them smiley which is
awesome and if you look at how this is
laid out this is a space which means
that this is the row of numbers and this
is uppercase letters so that's an a
that's B that's a CB e f g h i j who's
ever received an email where somebody
typed the sentence ended with a capital
J that's a smiley K L has anybody ever
seen an email with a capital L well I
had that one once so these are just
letters and somebody on Windows says
this must be rendered in wingdings and
as long as you have wingdings
and your your email client interpreted
correctly you will get a smiley and
you'll be none the wiser
outlook still does this in 2019 when we
have emoji we've had them for like 5 to
10 years now it still does this that
brings us to emoji so emoji stands for e
picture and moji character the picture
message and they're really popular
because come on just look at them you're
using the pillows sitting in the couch
looking at you like that that's just I
like them they're awesome and emoji
allow you to do really complicated
things because if you just take an emoji
and then add a modifier to it we can
make it into a woman or a man or we can
make their skin color different or maybe
we can add a thing called a zero-waste
joiner to join up to emoji so instead of
having a man and a woman you have a
couple we can go make an entire family
and get their sexist correct so we can
have two women married with a son and a
boy a girl and a daughter we can have a
dark-skinned family this is awesome but
emoji do have downsides because this is
nice way of using emoji people use them
for bad as well so the first one is that
this symbol is mostly replaced with the
water gun and I thought it was
everything until I typed it and it shows
up as an actual gun because everybody
replaced it acceptable into how well a
knife a gun and a bomb these are really
well suitable for telling somebody
what you're going to do to them this is
not a nice way to talk to people but
then you get to the next line and you're
like an aubergine and a peach I don't
think I need to explain what people do
with that so yes people do that but yeah
they've actually been proposes in
Unicode to change the standard
representation of a peach so that it
looks like less likely but which was
rejected because come on people and in
some point somebody in India threatened
to sue whatsapp because they allowed you
to use the middle finger symbol which is
inspiring hate and that's something
that's not allowed by Indian law so they
try to sue them so let's go to Unicode
abuse because this is fun so we have a
salbo text has anybody seen the outgo
text yeah so sell go Texas made in order
to make something look really distorted
and it's used just by using Unicode we
take regular text we add some combining
diacritics so Adam - to the L add some
things on top and below everybody else
then we add some tons more somebody has
a bug in their rendering that's supposed
to be over there and then we add even
more so we mess up the entire string so
that it's barely readable you'll see the
salgo text at the top right and then we
have this which looked like a nice
druggie somebody standing there like
that but actually this is just Unicode
so this is a Michael a backslash an
underscore open brace Japanese hiragana
closing brace underscore slash Michael
so this is just nine Unicode characters
in a row and other is then the hiragana
character you wouldn't have thought
about this but it just looks so much
like a smiley that somebody decided I'll
gonna make that and then we get the
worst of all which is making things look
upside-down
so when you read this upside down it
looks okay because it doesn't look that
terrible but actually all of these
letters are just stolen from something
else so this n is actually you you this
you it's actually an N it's kind of odd
that some of these are from different
script
speaking of different scripts there's a
thing online where if you have a domain
name you can have them in your native
language and people started using that
because we use imitation letters from a
different script to resemble something
so keep your fingers crossed we're going
to try a live demo so we have two apples
we're going to try to take our browser
and go to Apple yes I will so we go to
Apple this is Apple we know that and
then let me find the right slides we're
quite a way along actually that's good
so we go for the second row and I'm
pretty sure that nobody noticed a
difference so let's go to Apple calm
does this look like Apple
yeah that's Apple this is obviously not
Apple and this is not me hacking my
browser or anything this is five
Cyrillic letters so the P is pronounced
are o and the other ones were also just
Cyrillic GLaDOS which means that my
browser thinks this is just a Cyrillic
word and I'm trying to go to however you
pronounce it but for me this looks like
Apple calm so I'm not expecting this at
all and this was abused a lot for trying
to hack people but it appears that most
things can't be spelled in just Cyrillic
s-- so the only way to do this is to mix
characters so you have one Cyrillic and
one Latin letter and that doesn't happen
in official domain names which means
that that one was liked by browsers and
in that case it will
not displayed as Sevilla clatters they
will just display the underlying puny
coded name so this is an issue but it's
not as much of an issue as it might seem
so the first one is actually Apple
second one is Cyrillic if you compare
them you can notice that this is just a
pixel or two to the right but that's
about the only way I can see this so
then we go to encoding Unicode encoding
is easy we'll never need more than
65,000 characters so we'll just put it
in UCS - we'll call that the 16-bit
encoding we'll just put everything in
that what if we need to make this ASCII
compatible like calling an operating
system function that only does ASCII
well we'll create a tier ut of six utf-8
and just put it in there
ASCII compatible it doesn't have back
slashes or anything so anybody searching
for back slashes is going to work just
fine this is awesome
but what if you want to email something
we'll put in a UT f7 which is a mime
compatible format from putting Unicode
text in okay but how do we now recognize
if we do utf-8 rather than Latin 1 or
Windows 1252 well just take a byte order
mark which is a character that has no
meaning in utf-8 and put it at the front
because everybody knows it has no
meaning they'll just ignore it and have
text read as utf-8 awesome but kind of
weird but now we need more characters
okay so let's take you cs2 and take some
region of that that was reserved use
that for expanding into a larger set of
terraces call the new encoding utf-16
and tell people this is now the new
encoding and you will need to be using
this and switching through this from you
cs2 is really easy so no issues
whatsoever but what if it's brought to a
computer with big-endian encoding I will
put a byte order mark at the start and
we'll do big onion utf-16 a little
endian utf-16 but now now I can't just
go over it like it's a byte array or a
character array Oh we'll make utf-32
and yes you get byte order mark and big
onion little onion all that stuff but
now what if I want to be able to read a
utf-8 stream 1ut f6
scene or use he has to point at a time
what why would you do this this doesn't
make any sense you do you shouldn't read
code Eunice you should read code points
and okay
see is you eight we can do this it's
kind of insane this is used by Java
because for some reason they found this
interesting it does mean that if you're
trying to decode utf-8 or utf-16 and go
one code point at a time you get to have
an integer place to break at okay maybe
I use but now what if I take this and
make that transportable across the space
that can also not handle nulls so we can
take some utf-16 transcoder too bad
utf-8 and then add in null characters so
that we can actually ship the null
characters over a null terminated byte
string interface yeah that's Android I
don't exactly know why they want this
but Android does this but what if I use
F stick and you want to use Unicode well
switch stop using EPSA dick but of
course that's not the answer you get we
have UCF episode ik which is a Unicode
compatible and episodic compatible
encoding to get Unicode across an IBM
system huh okay this one's horrible but
what if I'm Chinese and I used to use
gbk we can't just switch everything from
gbk to some kind of UTF encoding people
are not going to be able to understand
it we want something that's backwards
compatible
okay so let's invent gb 1803 which takes
a one or two body encoding for all the
stuff that's in gb k and then has a for
bind encoding for everything that's
actually in unicode - all the things
that are already in gb k so encoding -
this is an absolute nightmare requires
like a couple of megabytes of look-up
tables and is very slow but it exists
okay so then how would do we display
this well it's kind of easy just map a
character to a glyph calculate the
position for a glyph draw the glyph like
figure out there's D this size the icons
after it display D D and so on
just repeat
unicode is different because now we
don't just have ascii characters we
don't just have latin 1 characters
hebrew which is the other way around but
otherwise still simple we have combining
diacritics we can put a dot on an eye we
could put a second dot on an eye or like
5 we can have languages started
right-to-left
we can have cases where somebody quotes
a hebrew person in english or somebody
in in israel putting somebody in english
which means say you need to layout that
somehow that is readable for people not
used to this then we have Korean and
there Fagin Ari de Santa Gary yes which
is used in India and those scripts
combine characters into more complicated
shapes which means that if you want to
write that you need to have some kind of
combining and shaping to make that
happen which is really complicated
because hey you need to detect it and
then B you need to display it and then
we get ligatures and the dutch european
ones american ones they're easy but the
arabic ones they are horribly
complicated so to do this we decode the
unicode code points we normalize the
code points we have one representation
for everything we extract the grapheme
closest so just like combining
characters and your actual character we
shape them to determine where they go
and then we render them where they
should go
that's easy so now we go to C++ yeah so
tip of us in 1989 we have no support
whatsoever for Unicode because it wasn't
invented unicode started in 91 so of
course we don't have any support then we
got to 98 we have standard string we
have standard white string which is the
current locale which may not actually be
what you think it is and what characters
are defined to be wide enough to hold
any character in your encoding which
means that windows chooses 16 bit
because that's fine it fits everything
in use here - I didn't have a whole lot
of handling for Unicode and everything
it did have come from C because we have
white characters to multiply characters
multiplied to white characters we can go
back and forth between the two but
there's not really way to handle utf-8
at all so let's fast forward to go to
2011 because it took
to get new standard we have stood you 16
string and car 16 which is actually
utf-16 then we gets used 32 string and
car 32 t apologies for the w and IC
utf-32 string this looks fine we have
support and we have su drag X which has
no support whatsoever for unicode it
doesn't even understand that if you have
utf-8 that two bytes behind each other
might need to combine its it's not even
fixable so Stu drag X if you want to do
Unicode is just broken don't use it we
are working on something else
and we don't have any utf-8 character
type or string type because we at 16 and
32 but for some reason we didn't get 8
yeah so let's fast forward to 2014 where
we get absolutely nothing
it's just what we had in 2011 because
this was a bug fix release and this
didn't do a whole lot for a c-plus in
terms of strings so 2017 we get study
group 16 formed in late 2017 so it's not
actually people for 17 anymore and we
get string literals so we have the u8a
you and a capital u for utf-8 utf-16 and
utf-32 except that the utf-8 one is just
a character but a character array might
just be some local encoding so it's kind
of odd to have this it doesn't make
sense we need to have a way to keep
these two apart
so as you sixteen pushes to get some
kind of 8-bit car type maybe like car 8t
you know and then you a string to make
everything match up and logical so yeh
we get that 2020 we will have a car 80
we will have a u8 string it will be
utf-8 we changed u8 to be actually char
80 because come on and this is a
breaking change which means that if you
used u8 up to this point this may change
the way your code works it may break the
compilation but in honestly this is the
only sane way to do this and if we don't
do it now we're going to have to do
something similar later
it's gonna break even more we did look
how many people are using this and in a
code base of a couple hundred million
lines we found about 700 ish most of
which was in one project that's sort of
acceptable and we have you char and you
see you char which does multi by two you
a strain you 16 and you 32 so we can
read utf-8 it's great it's only 2020 and
we can even decode characters good job
but when we put it in the you a string
we can't actually use it because if you
have a string we can't construct it
easily from multi banner in white
characters it's AC function that we're
using and if we did we can't put it to
see out because if you try it's just
gonna say I can't print this I can't put
these NC out but maybe that's just my
problem trying to you see out which is
the single character output maybe we
should use the white one no that just
doesn't work so we have the types we
can't really use them for a lot kind of
annoying so where are we with displaying
Unicode in C++ we can decode them it's
mostly not in C++ but we can sort of can
do that we can normalize them but not in
C++ we can extract graphemes but not in
C++ we can shape them using external
libraries like harf bus and we can
render them using external libraries
like free type and they will do part of
this because otherwise it wouldn't be
usable but in order to edit stuff we
also need to do all the way up to this
which means we're kind of stuck so let's
go to our future perfect c plus 20 we
are going to lay the groundwork so we
take all the stuff that is actually
horribly broken and we try to fix it as
much as we can
so you eight needs abuse charity arrays
we need to have charities we have a
whole lot of detail fixes like if you
compile something on Windows with a
character in it that is representable in
the source encoding but not the
execution encoding it's just happily
gonna produce mode you bake for you it's
perfectly fine doing that and we're
trying to push that in so that if you
try to do that and your code would
compile to just garbage knowingly that
we tell the compiler to make an error
out of it
because it knows it's garbage
compile that and we make sure we get
references to the actual Unicode
standard into the C++ standards so that
the next generation we can just point to
that every time we need it instead of
having to refer to it in the hundred
different papers
it's just saving a lot of work so C plus
we need to get some text type we have to
be able to do cool points graphemes we
have to get some unicode support into
all the rest of the standards that needs
it
so we have stood rack X it's can't be
fixed it's just impossible but somebody
else wrote a really good compile time
regular expression if you haven't seen
her talk go to her talk and that's also
telling myself because I didn't go to
her talk it's going to be awesome and it
has unicode support as much as we can
muster at this point is already in it is
slated to go into sleep plus 23 as a
standard compile time red X because
somebody used to name drag X and it's
going to have actual Unicode support so
you can check that something contains
non ASCII characters is something
contains emoji and we have a direction
paper which basically explains what kind
of stuff we're going to do so that's a
link if anybody's interested I will send
it around so what else do we do we make
some guidelines like when do you
actually convert your data and we try to
get you to convert it as soon as
possible when you enter your program
change everything to utf-8 all your
internal logic will be utf-8 and try to
normalize it when you get to the border
the normalization is a bit more
complicated because if you paste two
strings together they need to be
normalizing to be in normal form again
so that is something we will have to
support inside the program but every bit
of encoding we hope that we can convince
everybody just use utf-8 everywhere and
this is not something that SG 16 came up
with there is a push globally about
utf-8 everywhere on utf-8 everywhere org
seems obvious and they basically explain
why this is the only sitting choice for
the rest of the future and why we should
try to do this as much as possible and
so far I think about 97% of the internet
is currently in utf-8 so it looks to be
going in this direction the best thing
we can do is go along with that so then
we have SG 16 as you sixteen is trying
to get there
but we have some challenges if you have
any questions about this stuff please
feel free to ask us on the mailing list
you can contact Tom hahnemann directly
he is the chair of as you 16 I've asked
him specifically if it's fine to put his
email address on slides that everybody's
going to see he's fine with that so feel
free to ask him any questions so I'll
leave you with this one question do you
go down the rabbit hole what do you want
to stay where you are
[Laughter]
this was unicode going down the rabbit
hole thank you
[Applause]